hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play lost the lights okay I found
some oil
I found a way over to the oil ooh
there's also laudanum sanity potion
Oh large oil oh yeah
found that so great at this game ooh
another no okay
nobody likes jails but it's better than
living in the safe we need the jail for
our safety if people are going crazy are
starting to kill another they need to be
locked up I don't know why this is
happening magic
come on door a door right next to a door
[Music]
okay huh okay all right someone just got
murdered another person
okay Emily's going to mate tinderboxes
or I'm not using enough I do up quite a
few favourite Ripper cannot use this
item this way got ya
I gotcha where do I go shut up [ __ ]
I'm running away got my eyes on both try
to onion cross my eyes both hallways
where is it where is it where is it
where is it I know hey buddy how's it
going hey buddy you down there I know
you're not down there you down there No
are you still there hello I know
okay here's that giant damn grunt he
killed them I wish I had more time to
save them I'm not saving anybody by
myself it's that pot that I was supposed
to get for the acid stuff very dark very
[Music]
shut up guys now I'm gonna deal with
your crap right now no uh-uh no I know
you didn't I know you didn't
oh I see you um see a little bit of some
see a little Samsung okay that's right
music gone yeah else nothing with
nothing probably like some of these
nothing back you son of a [ __ ]
Benny box
Benny's bitty box Benny much baby spin
their box
no governor damn it box is this bigger
box
you got oh don't go down the hole that's
oh man oh man okay that's that was
something I wasn't that scared okay come
on can I go down it oh I need a hammer
tip it
Oh scheisse
oh boy even if alphas are joelle wait
for the large one
oh right left left dead end
okay alright it's okay I'm okay okay
just in some weird cave okay okay okay
nothing's happened up did it all right
I'm okay I'm so brave that took them
weeks man on like no joke come
[Music]
Oh
oh no no no you bastard
you bastard you bastards
how could you do that why would you do
that that's just wrong why would you do
that Oh Oh No
Oh God it was like oh so I found these
Trig's ah oh you bastards
oh you rat bastards oh oh okay oh boy oh
boy oh oh dear goodness Oh me
John here homeboy there's the same
tunnel a different title I it was like
because I just chipped it I didn't click
on the door icon to go through I just
chipped it so this is still blocked and
is this way oh man oh oh you diabolical
bastard oh you bastard oh I made this
hole in case of collapse I broke the
person cell lock so nobody can discover
the secret hole go back into the hole
and find the crowbar to break it go back
into the hole and find the crowbar
alright I got it
okay I gotta go find a crowbar wait no
can I just chip it alright whatever I
gotta go back in oh don't like this hole
oh man
I just oh god oh my god
I'm like totally wary of these caves now
oh oh man okay okay
Oh feels evil here I should be aware oh
man
chair no chair come with me waiting with
it is oh so dark down here
should that nope okay that's just a log
there we go that's the Oh another chair
but nothing else I'll stick with a first
chair okay next door loud open another
chair
get a chair are me going on here okay
chair you watch the back end we'll move
forward
bring it on oh you're not getting me
this time Oh what up what up son of a
[ __ ] alright alright time to get tough
time to get tough on these suckers
oh whoa you ain't gonna gimme I'm so
tough that brave I'm only checking that
time every few seconds to make sure her
to eagerly anticipate the end of this
episode
oh god
okay good thing cherry covered the back
there but the other chair didn't do no
good he just pushed it away
I didn't even effective got chair come
on okay if you failed me I'm like
Chinese here here we go here's another
one come here come on arrived Oh want
some huh yeah
get open I don't even need a chair I
hear a lot of people crying in the
background
people need to toughen up it's not that
bad here
oh not enough not enough I don't
halo-halo chests are nothing in here
trol chest oh come on I need oil I need
oil soon or else I'm gonna just fall
over and die
well isn't my men all damn it I need to
find a key to open this bloody door you
investigate the area I'm giving myself
objectives now
where am I I thought this was leaving
back chest oh oh oh I hit the mother
lode oh look at this oh my goodness oh
my goodness gravy Wow okay that's good
hello memo hotel I feel a wind blowin
rather strong but where there's a breeze
there's a breeze to be found
ah oh yeah Oh too smart by half oh yeah
[Music]
I feel like there was a lot left out
there that I didn't you know do anything
with come on come on can I get out here
there we go ah ah you bastard oh oh he
was working with chair
Jerez kiss me let's play oh I can't take
it I'm old I'm 23 now do this man this
sorry thank you thank you I am out of
time for this episode oh oh yeah all
right thank you everybody so much for
watching hope you enjoyed this one i am
i certain li did and as always i'll see
you in the next part
bye bye